welcome everybody we have another press
briefing on our hands today I anticipate
that this one is going to be very
interesting this will be Kaley maca
nanny's first press briefing since
Donald Trump claimed to be taking
hydroxy chloroquine for a couple of
weeks now this will be the first press
briefing since Donald Trump's tweets of
threats to both Nevada and Michigan over
withholding money if indeed they decide
to vote by mail which is of course
completely against federalism it's
completely against states rights which
Donald Trump claims to be in favor of so
we're going to hopefully see questions
on those issues and others to Kaylee Mac
and Annie scheduled for the top of the
hour just eight minutes from now seven
minutes from now I guess but often
starting late the trend with Kaylee Mac
and Annie has been she starts 30 to 40
minutes late and does only a 20 to 25
minute press briefing very often as five
or six minute statement and then 15 20
minutes of questions often ending
abruptly after a prepared response to a
what Trump would characterize as a nasty
question so we'll see if today follows
that same pattern we will be off on
Memorial Day there will be no new show
with peace and love no new show on
Memorial Day it'll be the first sort of
like planned day off other than weekends
for the show really of the year because
with the virus we've just all been at
home working so we've just been doing
the show so Monday we will be off and we
will be back with content on Tuesday but
we still got this stream we've got
tomorrow's show and bonus show Friday
show and bonus show a plenty to look
forward to let me say an early and quick
thank you to Ian Jarrah's because Ian
just signed up on my website join
pakman.com that makes me predisposed to
think Ian is a really good person and
that would be probably accurate in in
most cases we'll get back to members
momentarily let's get to some super
chats those are starting to come in they
will eventually show up in that gray up
that way that gray box in the lower left
of the screen the first couple never do
because there
kind of further up Bernie Sanders asks
why do you prefer single-payer over the
public option oh I've got dozens of
videos on that I'm not I'm not gonna go
into that now
mark Fillion says how how are your
favorite authors fiction and nonfiction
they're doing well no I assume you mean
who are I have so many favorite authors
that you'd really have to UM
you'd have to narrow it down like
science nonfiction versus narrative
nonfiction sigh five versus crime versus
the eye I read so much that it would be
really really hard to narrow it down
Jason Ealing says bro what was that
tweet I have no clue what you're talking
about Jason I have no idea what you're
talking about I apologize
you're gonna have to be a little more
specific than that a little more
specific than that and remember if you
are watching on YouTube always always
always like and subscribe very very
important let's go over to twitch
momentarily I want to say thanks to
smash can as well as UK Marxism DLC
failed that's a mouthful of a username
for subscribing with twitch prime very
much appreciate it and really love that
twitch twitch is doing better and better
from this from the standpoint of
followers twitch is doing better than
better as many of you know I've only
been I've been on YouTube for years I've
only been on twitch for nine months and
we've got about 35,000 twitch followers
which is great it's a great start and
it's uh it's just a work in progress
over back on YouTube thanks to Bjorn
Eric Knutson who has upgraded his
membership to beta hello Justin Quran
says via super chat biggest fear is
abide and win energizes trumpets and
centrists become complacent and we lose
the house and more of the Senate in the
midterms then lose the presidency in
2024 well you're you're thinking very
very far ahead that's not a bad thing
but let's let's worry about this
election right now Barney
mcdhh an ache says David Pakman
misspelled my last name
how are your Tomatoes they're good I
have a video of a full urban garden tour
on my phone which I filmed I haven't
uploaded it yet actually I did upload it
if you follow me on library that's lb ry
TV and you should if you follow me there
and make sure to say I referred you I
have a full two and a half minute really
almost a three-minute garden tour of
everything I show people my cukes I
exposed my tomatoes I show people my
sprouts I mean I'm lifting I'm lifting
the veil off of everything but I've not
yet posted that anywhere sort of like
more mainstream I guess I would say
Donna Williams says do you think Trump
is really taking hydroxy yeah I actually
doubt it if you said David you are going
to be able to know for sure do you bet
that he's taking it or bet that he's not
my I would probably bet that Trump is
not taking hydroxy chloroquine as he
says it oh by the way did you notice
Trump glitched yesterday at one point
did you notice this Trump seemed to
forget the name of the drug and just so
you understand great studies came out of
Italy on hydroxy you know what I'm
talking about right right great studies
Canada so he seemed to lose his train of
thought there and then this one was also
weird many many doctors doctors many
doctors came out let me look at hydroxy
just one more time I like this one and
just so you understand great studies
came out of Italy on hydroxy you know
what I'm talking about right right great
studies came out so anyway that was that
was yesterday and then here's Trump
calling a reporter rude and saying
that's enough of you this was yesterday
so I'm very disappointed in China yeah
are you any closer to a decision on that
sir I don't talk about retaliation go
ahead mr. president why haven't you
announced a plan to get 36 million
unemployed Americans back to work you're
overseeing historic economic despair I
think we've announced a plan we're
opening up our country just a rude
person you are we're opening up our
country but the plan is that each state
is opening and it's opening up very
effectively and when you see the numbers
I think even you will be impressed which
is pretty hard to impress you yeah go
ahead no more of you so anyway that was
yesterday and today we're standing by
for the Kayle Bank mcenany press
briefing thanks to political puppy for
the twitch subscription has been
subscribed for six months absolutely
love it let's deal with a few other
YouTube super chats as I call them pair
T Ren says live long and prosper my
friend may your psyche be strong in this
trying times love from Sweden great to
hear from you pair Adam White says what
do you think of the handful of
scientists state workers coming out
saying they were cough requested to
alter state koban numbers I report about
the Florida case today on the show and
if even 5% of what is being alleged is
true it's sick absolutely sick Bernie
Sanders says why do you take super chats
when you don't answer questions this is
Alex Jones I have been off for a few
weeks I am back at rolling you yeah it's
because I just don't answer questions
from people that I know are trying to
either derail the stream or get me to
attack other youtubers or just get me
off on tangents the streams are not the
same as my YouTube clips if I'm gonna do
you know 15 minutes on public option as
we get to a close to a start public
option versus medicare-for-all I'm going
to be fully prepared with notes and
research I'm not going to go off the
cuff off on something so serious when
we're just doing a live event here and I
didn't know that Bernie Sanders was was
the user who used to troll me as Alex
Jones but I inferred
it was just someone trying to derail me
so that's the answer
Alexander the Snivy says remember that
we still have to get through 2020 s
hurricane season which is predicted to
be an extremely active season in light
of climate change yes we still have
potentially many hurricanes coming up
ahead of us let me say thank you - Who
am I saying thank you - here ardella
forest is new member number two today on
my website join pakman.com and Matt
lovren
is new member number three today at join
pakman.com very very much appreciate
your support thank you so much really
really do appreciate that it's been a
tough couple months for the show and
thanks to members signing up during the
streams and in general we have been
buoyed buoyed is the way I like to put
it Paul Newman says no offense to the
monkey in times of kovat 19 and climate
change you have to do what you have to
do forget about the monkey take care of
the issues that matter I have no clue
what that means I have absolutely no
idea what that means
ken Clive says out of many good things
to come out of Italy Ferrari designed an
open-source low-cost ventilator anyone
can build Formula One teams have
repurposed their factories to make PPE
as well I've read a little bit about
that and that is fantastic news Barra so
I'm noticing that two reporters just
left the room can anybody get me an
update as to whether the streaming has
been delayed because usually when people
leave it's a sign that it may have been
postponed just I mean I'll be here but
I'm just curious if anybody knows why
they both just left the room usually
they stay in the room if they're about
to start let's see if I can look at
press secretary Twitter sometimes they
announce there let's take a look here
Caylee McKenna and Annie did not tweet
anything about that so I'm not seeing
that there and doesn't seem like anybody
else knows for that about that for sure
okay if anybody know maybe send it to me
be a super chat and get my attention
that way
Whitehouse still says 3 p.m. yeah I know
still says I know that the White House
rarely changes the schedule at this late
stage but sometimes there's like a tweet
that somebody will announce a change or
something like that ok very good Barry
mcdhh and fake so Barney Barney McDaniel
says I feel terrible for misspelling
your name here's a five-dollar apology
thanks for all your hard work mr. Pakman
thank you Jason Ellen says the only fans
tweet sorry got being specific oh yeah I
I jokingly tweeted earlier because some
people on stream told you to make told
me to make an only fans account so I
tweeted earlier so I made an only fans
account because viewers told me to what
happens next
and somehow 1,100 people liked it and
somebody said here wait are you being
serious or is this my sense of humor
absent the moment I looked into what it
is and I determined it's not the right
thing for me so no I am NOT going to be
posting content on only fans but the
tweet did very very well from the
standpoint of likes the tweet did very
very well let me say thank you to Kay
Henry listen if I really made the
account I would have linked to it and
said follow me right I mean I'm not
gonna waste an opportunity for promotion
you all know that Kay Hendricks is new
member number four today on my website
at join pakman.com thank you I
appreciate that
remember that if you are watching on
twitch there's this and even if you're
not quite frankly there's something
called twitch prime okay if you have
Amazon Prime which I know many of you do
every month twitch gives you one free
subscription that you can use alright
you pay nothing but for me it counts as
a paid subscription you've got to link
up your amazon and twitch accounts you
go to twitch amazon.com it's beautiful
it's a beautiful beautiful thing Killick
am just did it and is our newest twitch
prime subscriber and it's something I
would encourage people to do from the
perspective of supporting independent
media I'm inconsolable also just gifted
five subscriptions which is delightful
delightful okay
Kamala Reichert's says my underst
is that hydroxy is given to our soldiers
as a preventative measure before going
overseas for malaria I would imagine not
if you're saying , would that it's being
given prophylactically for two soldiers
for kovat 19 I would want to hear about
that Dan same ol Ange says hi David will
you do a segment on Lauren's ham in New
Jersey he's a Bernie progressive running
against Booker haven't heard of it I
will look into it pear tieran says those
who left were going to make a mini
journalist delivery time nine months
I love pear he's one of our biggest
supporters from from Sweden but I often
don't know what pear is talking about
Saylor Avon says when you won the Rajoy
al you were worried that destiny was
going to a fan meet up with fan meetups
does the Paris social aspect make you
feel weird uh no in my experience what's
tough about fan meetups
I've talked hilariously I've talked to
Jay Tomlinson host of best of the left
podcast about this I don't want to get
stuck in the corner with someone who
sort of like lacks the social
understanding that there's a bunch of
people who want to say hi to me I don't
want to get stuck in the corner with one
person the whole time who tries to
manipulate my time and I have a few
strategies for getting out of it but
I've had this conversation with Jay from
best to the left he doesn't even seem to
notice like Jay once we did a joint
Young Turks best of the left David
Pakman I think Sam cedar meetup
hilariously Sam I think didn't go to his
own meetup if I recall correctly this
was at a conference one year maybe and
might have been where was it Minnesota
or God I don't remember where it was
somewhere anyway we did a joint meetup
if I recall correctly it was a Sam cedar
David Pakman best of the left TYT meetup
Sam didn't even go to his own Meetup can
you imagine a more alpha move than not
going to your own meetup it was stunning
but anyway Jay just will talk to one
person for two hours and then after I'll
be like but are you like stuck with that
guy stuck what buddy what do you mean so
know that that's not my concern with
meetups the Paris social aspect it's not
that there are a number of other
concerns and that is not one of them
Adrienne benningfield says a good
readings here a good book series is
chronicles of amber I have not heard of
that let me say thank you to Wagner rock
for subscribing on Twitch Karoshi chafe
girl huh
Paul McCrory all of whom have subscribed
over on Twitch very much appreciate that
I also want to say thank you to James
Engel who is new member number five
today and Natalie Linton who is member
number six at join pakman.com very much
appreciate your support
mark Fillion says what do you think
about the orange buffoon saying that if
they tested less than they would have
fewer cases in a literal sense we would
have fewer confirmed cases of course
testing doesn't change the number of
cases you actually have or people are
saying my audio is low now it seemed
it's at the normal level I don't see any
uh nothing's changed nothing's changed
for the last several months on audio
from the standpoint of audio levels I
think we're okay a zest the African says
the standpoint of water or the orange
talk from Trump also just graduated from
K you these streams are a gift awesome I
don't know what K U is is that Kansas
University congratulations though mr.
lieutenant pics pink says David if
you're looking for book reconnections I
highly recommend the sci-fi works of Ian
banks I've read a little bit of his work
very clever with lots of political
themes Ian banks I think I've read one
of his books he's very very good Peter
HAMP Peter F Hamilton is excellent yeah
a lot of a lot of good a lot of good
fiction out there right now oh let me
mention this this so so here's a book
recommendation I'm in touch with the
author Eliot Pepper that's with one P
pepper with one P and he sent me an
advance copy of his new book out today
Vail ve IL like you know vet and veiled
not like Vail Colorado the e IL I am
like ten pages from finishing it it's
great the book is out today so if you
grab it uh it's free with Kindle
unlimited on Amazon or you can buy it on
Kindle or the paper
I'm still on paper books quite frankly
send him a tweet send Elliott a tweet
and say I got your book because of David
Paquin's recommendation I get nothing
for it I just like building community I
love it when like I've recommended
people go to Michael's deli in Brookline
Massachusetts people go in and they say
to Steve it's Michael's deli but the
owner is Steve I'm here because of David
Pakman and it's great I get nothing free
from I get nothing out of it but it's
we're building community we're building
community the book is veil by by elliott
pepper let me say thank you to see
guests 85 for subscribing over on Twitch
prime thank you very much we are
standing by for Donald Trump's press
secretary Kaley Mackin Annie should be
starting very very soon we are ten
minutes late meaning we're probably 25
to 20 minutes from the start that's
where we are right now Phyllis tatl says
Rogen moving exclusively to Spotify what
are your thoughts I don't really have
any thoughts I mean you know it's it's
clearly a business decision I'm sure he
did it because it's the right decision
for him at this time I don't have any
problem with Spotify or YouTube or you
know I don't I mean it seems it seems
like an interesting move Seiler Avon
says my apologies for being slow to
respond calling in called from Skype so
the area code wasn't when I was
expecting I'm from Rhode Island right
south of you okay I don't know I don't
know exactly what you're referring to
but maybe we had a missed connection so
to speak on the phone lines I'm not
really sure keith sweat has subscribed
with twitch prime and says thoughts on
progressives turning on Obama his
presidency had issues but how productive
is that whole conversation at this point
in time completely unproductive it
listen some some progressive turned on
Bernie some progressives turned on Obama
I don't care what people do as long as
they own the consequences that's all I
watch and and be intellectually honest
about what you are doing and why you are
doing it
s Jimenez has subscribed with twitch
Prime as well and I very very much
appreciate that let me invite you
consider yourself personally invited to
support these streams and all of our
work by grabbing a membership on my
website join pakman.com I get a very
frequent email I get is listened David
you've got twitch you've got patreon
you've got you know YouTube met all this
stuff I'm getting bashed over the head
I'm punched drunk I don't know how to
support you most directly the best way
is my website there is no intermediary
there's no one taking a big slice 510
30% slices that some of these platforms
take throw that in the trash throw that
in the trash bring it out to the curb
get that out of here the best way to
support us all of us who work on the
show is with a membership on my website
we're talking two bucks a month we're
talking a dollar 80 a month if you pay
for the entire year at once if you use
that coupon code in blue text above my
head look at that way it's over here
yeah yep there it is 2020 now you save
66 percent okay it takes under a minute
to sign up everybody gets a thank you we
have a very modest goal of 25 today and
I'm gonna I'll actually do so so here
let me let me do something as an extra
incentive or disincentive depending on
your perspective people have been
pointing out that my hair is getting
very long and talking about a man bun
I've independently confirmed over the
weekend that a man bun is possible right
now and I've been saying I would do it
if we get to 50 new members on a stream
forget about 50 we've we've not made it
to 50 at all this week if we just get to
25 today next stream I will have a man
bun and I want to mention that I may be
getting a haircut next week I may be
getting a haircut next week so we
probably only have a few streams of
opportunity remaining for what we are
going to call the man bun stream and if
you don't want that to happen also
become a member because then we'll get
it out of the way and then you don't
have to hear about it anymore and I
think that that is a probably the best
bet for every
buddy so that's what we have on the
table right now so to speak okay let me
get back to Oh I'll do a couple twitch
thank-yous Yuli darn or no hold on Yuli
damn has subscribed with prime and
typical college stud has also subscribed
with prime over on YouTube
super chats let's see here
Adam White says what do you think of
businesses asking for 24 weeks of PPP
loan paybacks and forgiveness but tea
boys gang saying 10 to 12 weeks should
be fine they don't know what's going on
the business owners know what's going on
I would defer to the business owners for
sure oh we do have a level 4 hype train
happening on twitch right now we have 30
seconds left to close out level 4 and
we're 78 percent of the way there we may
be able to do it let's just take 25
seconds just to see if it happens
because we've not completed level for 4
weeks at this point 17 seconds to go
78 percent of the way there could we do
it 10 seconds to go
oh boy it's about to not happen 5
seconds to go and we did it we did it we
made level 4 has been completed on a
twitch hype train unbelievable thanks to
Zanna Max and a Munden and she so lion
dog unbelievable ladies and gentlemen we
have not achieved that for a very very
long time and O level 5 is happening now
we've got five minutes on level 5 and I
think we just did that I don't know
what's going on things are blinging and
blanking and i don't know what's going
on okay very good we did it we did the
hype train let's see what else is on
folks Minds waffles jirafa --ls says i
thought mmm
mikhail i maggin Annie was pretty
spot-on yeah I like Kaylee Magon Annie
like Maga nanny she's kind of like the
nanny for trumpets I think that it's a
good one I like it
parity Ren says have you read Stephen
Elson the six books of the unbeliever is
reread to shreds and now I shall buy
hardback instead warning the books our
district with lots of self-pity but I
love them
I have not read those books pear I have
not Matias Germany says two quests two
questions meet or Beyond meet coke or
Diet Coke I've tried some of the
elements of beyond Mead I didn't like it
I didn't like it
very very little red meat but you know
as many of you know I don't eat pork I
have found so I used to love kielbasa
okay but I don't I haven't eaten pork
for uh I guess six years and I recently
found turkey kielbasa absolutely
fantastic threw it on the grill last
week with a little brown spicy mustard
after the fact you don't grill the
mustard you just dip after Wow Wow
absolutely incredible I and I think I
had three elements of kielbasa and it
was really really good Coker Diet Coke I
haven't had a soda in I think also like
six or seven years so I I mean I don't
know much about it if you make me choose
whatever is sweetening Diet Coke I think
is worse for you than the corn syrup and
coke if I had to pick I would say a
foreign coke what I call Latin American
coke or European coke where it's
sweetened with sugar rather than corn
syrup that's the way I would I would go
with that but it doesn't if I'm wrong
that whatever Diet Coke is sweetened
with is bad I haven't had a soda in six
years I don't know anything about it
don't come it's like you know you don't
come to me for UFC commentary you don't
come to me for soda commentary because I
know nothing about it a bacon lover says
speaking of pork why do you not pause
the stream when fact-checking if I did
that we would it would the stream would
the the it would just take too long we
would fall further and further behind
live and I've made the decision that I
will just mute or kind of talk over to
fact-check that's the decision for now
once I did the pausing and people got to
me and said it's taking too long to get
through the event like the event is
doubling or tripling in duration and you
know a lot of people don't have time for
that that sort of thing so it was a
judgment call
I completely admit it was a judgment
call but that's the way we've done it
and also I want to thank Scott
Christianson for signing up on YouTube
at the SOI boy level very very much
appreciate that okay let me say a few
other thank-yous to folks who have
signed up on my website who do we have
here Amy Richardson is new member number
seven today thank you Amy
I appreciate that alejandro soto
is number eight today at join pakman.com
samantha marks is new member number 9
today Thank You Samantha
Greg watts is new member number 10
number 11 today is Maggie Vasquez number
11 lucky 11 Jackie Hayes is new member
number 12 at join pakman.com and then
Regina hey Shen Regina tation I hope I'm
pronouncing that correctly is number 13
and lastly for now Albert Cohen is new
member number 14 today 14 the target is
25 and if we get there my next stream
will be done with a man bun and this
could be an absolutely critical mistake
or my career but I'm going to do it
because I've promised it and I will it
will be one time and one time only and
then that's going to be it gonna be over
we're not gonna keep we're not gonna
keep the man-bun stuff going on let me
say a few thank-yous over on Twitch Oh
Orion Orion has gifted five
subscriptions sure oh she has cheered
again Zor loth has subscribed with
twitch Prime and I believe I already
thanked a Munden and Zane max or ZeniMax
I think and if I'm thanking you a second
time
then all the better all the better let's
look at the latest official Kovac
numbers we'll keep the audio up just so
we don't miss the start of this a great
event an event of truth and transparent
see the official global coronavirus
cases have now surpassed 5 million and
327 thousand deaths - nearly 2 million
people have recovered if we look at
yesterday's numbers in the middle of the
day the numbers don't tell us much
because different countries report at
different times if we look at yesterday
the USA again number one in new cases
although Brazil is really giving us a
run for our money both in cases and
deaths Brazil Russia and India I've been
watching these countries for 10 to 14
days there were early signals that they
were going in the very much wrong
direction and indeed Brazil Russia and
India doing very very poorly very very
poorly Saudi Arabia increasingly having
a problem Mexico now is regularly in the
top cases so we're seeing a little bit
of a transition the constant is us
number one in cases us number one in
deaths that's a constant but we are
seeing a shift from Italy Spain and the
UK right up there they have moved down
and instead we are seeing Brazil Russia
India Peru is having a real problem
Chile Saudi Arabia Mexico so we're
seeing a little bit of a changing of the
gaurd so to speak here in the United
States were approaching 1.6 million
official cases and we are just a few
days from a tragic milestone of 100,000
deaths again looking at yesterday the
most new cases now California taking the
top spot followed by Maryland and
Illinois for a long time it was New York
and New Jersey that were at the top
Massachusetts also often at the top but
we have thankfully of started to improve
let's just look just to pick one state
this is my state of Massachusetts if you
look at the trajectory here it's
improving its improving when it comes to
new cases when we look at deaths also if
you look at a rolling average those
numbers are improving so that's the data
there in terms of testing I'm not gonna
you know give you BS about the total
number of tests which really tells us
very little we again tested right around
four
thousand people yesterday it's certainly
better than 200,000 it's certainly
better than a hundred thousand we need
to be somewhere between one and a half
and three to five million tests a day
depending on who you ask and we are only
a fraction of the way there so that is
all of course very very unfortunate and
we need a lot more testing before we are
going to be really in a good place to
safely reopen restaurants and a lot of
these other parts of society for lack of
a better term let me say thank you to
Daniel Basha or Busha who is new member
number 15 today at join pakman.com Thank
You Daniel so appreciate your support
also Deanna bar cozy I hope is the right
pronunciation is new member number 16
today at join pakman.com thank you so
much I appreciate that let me answer a
few other questions coming in via super
chat here bacon lover says talking over
the misinformation is a big pork move
couldn't say it better myself
and Rob has subscribed on YouTube at the
soy boy level people asking about
YouTube subscription vs. website
subscription so website subscription
gets you access to the member part of my
website the full commercial free show
the bonus show Members Only newsletter
etc etc YouTube subscription mostly gets
you cool badges next to your chats in
the feed and a couple of other things
and we also have some pretty high levels
of support on YouTube okay people are
filing back into the press room so that
seems that seems to bode well unknown
prodigy asks do you wear contacts and
what is your favorite color do you mean
what's my favorite color in general or
what's my favorite color of contact
I wear a clear contact just they're not
I don't know if these are two different
questions I don't have a favorite color
cerulean would be up there but I don't I
don't really have a favorite color
that's a joke by the way and I do wear
contact lenses would be very very
difficult to see all
all of these screens if I did not have
contacts on shred 315 says even if I
don't agree with some things you do I
appreciate your work without the Mucha
way way is slang for dude in Mexico got
it got it
Lisa B says do you think Dems cancelling
election in New York and Georgia
Republicans canceling election for Judge
seat we are setting a precedent for
Trump to cancel November election listen
Trump can't cancel the November election
because we have federalism there are 50
elections and you would need to have 50
different governor's try to cancel them
but what I this on day one and by the
way a judge said that the New York
primary has to happen so that is back on
what happening in Georgia I we have to
see if you fear Trump is going to try to
pull funny business in November because
of coronavirus like even if you fear
that he will try why would you cancel a
primary that's an unprecedented step why
would you do it I thought it was a
boneheaded decision in New York it's
been undone by a judge and we'll see
what happens in in Georgia but terrible
terrible decision completely disagree
with it
neo Panther chick has subscribed with
twitch prime thank you so much very much
appreciate it also want to say thank you
to let me see if I can get this right
Gino Jian se or Jian Eskie who is new
member number 17 at join pakman.com Ryan
Ernst is new member number 18 today at
join pakman.com and Evan t-ball is new
member number 19 you know what I sort of
regret now saying that I would do a man
bun stream if we get to 25 because we
actually might make it now and I may
very quickly regret that but I obviously
can't take it back now I could delete
the record of the stream and pretend I
never said it but it's probably too late
for that at this point thank you to FP
vigilante for subscribing with twitch
Prime and mine host 86 as well as
Captain Aiko all of whom have
subscribed with twitch Prime I see a lot
of people who were skeptical that I
could even do a man bun right now
I absolutely could I absolutely could I
tested it over the weekend and my hair
is now five days longer but I don't know
if you can see I've got a I've got
something there which could absolutely
be whoa could absolutely become a man
bun it could absolutely happen and it
may happen if things continue the way
they are going right now okay it looks
like we're getting closer to the start
of today's press briefing let's take a
quick look as a lot of reporters are
filing in what is happening on Twitter
press secretary
what does press secretary say on Twitter
no update on the timing but we're about
a half hour late so my guess is that
it's going to start pretty soon as
people continue to file in our friend
here I don't know this guy's name but
our friend from Bloomberg has stepped in
and someone's raising their hand here I
don't know what that's about but that's
interesting I think we're gonna get
started very very soon here from the
standpoint of time we're going to get
started very very soon okay Bing says
what line crossed would equal extremists
action I have no idea what that question
means Mexicano TV says drop that only
fans link that was a joke guys yeah so
some people are wondering about that
earlier today I tweeted so I made an
only fans account because viewers told
me to what happens next it was a joke
you all know that I am very much into
promoting stuff if I was really on only
fans I would have included a link to it
and I didn't because I don't actually
have an only fans to promote so it is it
is just a joke just a joke nothing to
worry about
no only fans is going on honestly just
follow me on Instagram that's where I'm
posting the garden tours that's where
I'm posting I posted a very interesting
video of actually let me see if I can
find that do we have time for this
Instagram
dot-com / david dot pakman I'll show you
guys this just while we wait for the
stream to get going I posted video of
myself peeling a watermelon and dicing
it and I guess I did everything wrong
check this out
so I'm going right in there with a knife
I was told I'm using the wrong kind of
knife that this is the wrong way to cut
up a watermelon it's like I know this is
just a funny way to do it guys I
understand what someone said I shouldn't
throw away the peel that I should pickle
it I guess I wasted peel what else was I
told that my knife technique was no good
that my hair looked stupid that my shirt
looks stupid that it doesn't look like
I've been working out like ever I did
everything wrong apparently in this
video I'm complete it's a shock I can
even get my equipment turned on in the
morning right according to a lot of
people responding oh I also I didn't
realize I needed a really big container
and that I had all of these different
containers and subsequently they were
filled up and I needed more and more
containers guys just a 1 minute video of
me cutting up a watermelon we don't need
to you know this is not critical though
this is not spreading coronavirus this
has nothing to do with vaccines this has
nothing to do with national security
it's just fruit just fruit you know and
I did try a couple of pieces there so
that was that but you know if you're
looking for only fans type content as
best as I can gather just follow me on
Instagram cuz that's where you get high
quality content like like that Aaron
Dada says happy birthday David thank you
I don't know if you're three and a half
months late or eight and a half months
early but I always appreciate messages
of a happy birthday even if they don't
really line up with time I guess so to
speak a couple other people that I want
to thank Joshua Gilcrease is new member
number 20 today at join pakman.com KJ
Jenkins is new member number 21 George
Lynch is new member number 22 James
Graham is new member number 23 I'm gonna
have to do my hair in a man in a man bun
Xtreme aren't I because it looks like
we're certainly heading in the door
action of 25 new members today and then
it's it's going to have to happen
unknown prodigy says happy birthday from
me - I guess thank you but again it's
it's been months since my birthday it's
months until my birthday I don't know
what that is what what that is all about
there were people I saw asking me to do
an over-under for how quickly Kayleigh
Mack and Annie will lie so her first her
second press briefing we set it at 3
minutes and I took the over stupidly she
lied like 20 seconds in so then the next
briefing press briefing we did it at 20
seconds and she lied
12 seconds in and then we haven't done
it since because it's like usually the
first thing she says is a lie so it's
just it's just a waste I don't even
there's not even a point in doing an
over-under on Kaylee's first lie because
it's often it's like sometimes the the
first sentence is a lie and then it's
like I guess it was three seconds I
don't know Tina
6 9 9 3 has subscribed on YouTube and
booger-face very mature says just wanted
to say I like your hair thank you I
appreciate that I appreciate that very
much
Ryan Ernst and pear Terran also sending
me happy birthday wishes which of course
I love can't help but remind you that
you're a little bit late little foxes
says hey David
sorry that I cannot be a new member
apology accepted
apology accepted not day not a big deal
totally acceptable and fine you know a
better over-under for these would be
does it go more or less than 22 minutes
because some of these press briefings
have been insanely short where Kaylee
Mack and Annie will make like a five or
six minute presentation and only take
like 15 ish minutes of questions she
answers them pretty quickly and
succinctly so the over-under on the
duration of the entire event might be
more interesting like let's just imagine
if I said 23 minutes
do we think this will go longer or
shorter than 23 minutes today I don't
know I I really have no idea but we are
going to certainly keep an eye on a lot
of people saying under 23 minutes that's
interesting
Oh people are asking what is an
over/under okay
over/under would be like if you wanted
to bet I would say okay the over/under
is 22 you have to either bet that it
will be under 22 or over 22 so sometimes
like in sports betting you can do an
over/under on the combined score so like
the two teams together in football will
score 30 points you could take the over
or the under doesn't matter who scores
the points if it's 30 to 1 the over wins
if it's 16 to 15 the over wind that's
that's what we talk about when we say an
over/under I mean I think it's good that
a lot of my audience doesn't know about
sports betting that's but that actually
kind of bodes relatively well I like
that yeah I don't bet on anything so you
know I happen to know about some of this
stuff but I don't bet on anything any
other stuff let me say thank you to our
aquatic who says happy unbirthday the
empress AR says have a very merry
unbirthday sinful solution says happy
early birthday for next year wow that's
interesting and I want to say thanks to
Danny Belmonte who is new member number
24 today we are now just one member from
me having to wear my hair in a man bun
for the next stream that I do we're
getting extraordinarily close and I
think I just have to would concede that
it's probably going to happen and I will
be I will it will be a very different
David Pakman on the next on the next
stream Baron Steuben says if Biden winds
should Ruth Bader Ginsburg retire
immediately she declined to retire under
Obama well she should wait for Biden to
become president right
good afternoon everyone
I'd like to begin by detailing the
historic private public partnership
effort launched by the Trump
administration to combat the coronavirus
ad as both the businessman and as
president you'll all remember then
candidate Donald Trump now president
Donald Trump being adamant about
bringing manufacturing jobs back to
America right President Obama and the
Democrats had given up on manufacturing
with President Obama's erroneously
prediction that Trump would need a magic
wand in order to bring back American
jobs so that's not grammatical
erroneously prediction that's that's
weird you factoring in this country and
he tore up disastrous trade deals that
hemorrhaged American jobs like NAFTA and
like the plan that wasn't work the
trans-pacific partnership instead he put
in place better trade deals to bring
back American jobs and to bring back
American manufacturing and in the battle
against the invisible enemy President
Trump took action to shore up our
domestic supply chains in order to
deliver the necessary PPE and other
medical equipment to the States element
speaker Pelosi and House Democrats are
currently promoting a three trillion
dollar liberal which lists among a
litany of demos the priorities and
material to the coronavirus crisis are
embedded in this I think the Wicked
Witch of the East and West are on that
list school supplies response
coordinator who would quote serve as the
point of contact for the health care
system supply chain officials and the
states on medical supplies I'm happy to
report this individual already exists
this bill ignores reality because the
man is in what we call a script coma
where she's reading her notes with
strange inflection because she doesn't
even really understand what she's saying
more than 1 billion I should say pieces
of PPE two countries and hospitals
across the country since March 29th Rear
Admiral John Plouffe Czech vice director
for logistics for the Joint Chiefs has
been on the job as the head of FEMA
supply chain stabilization task force
this is a historic partnership with the
private sector and under the leadership
of President Trump FEMA directed the
greatest mobilization of the private
sector since World War two Rear Admiral
of check and FEMA quickly realized the
power of the private
during addressing the coronavirus
recognizing that the six largest private
sector medical distributors like just
the corporatist part of all of this a
lot of money being made on coronavirus
is essentially what she's saying billion
pieces of PPE in a single week that is
extraordinary volume by our private
sector notice that these numbers are
meaningless like pieces of PPE so like
each glove is a piece of PPE these
numbers mean nothing in the abstract
I am Rear Admiral pool of checks team
Huddle's with these six large private
sector medical distributors together
they review data compiled by dr. Burks
as well as information provided by the
CDC to set priorities and ensure
sufficient levels of supplies go down
not just to the county level but to the
hospital level after focusing
geographically Rear Admiral pull-up Jack
and his team Orient's the data to set
point of care distribution priorities
for public hospitals VA and DOD
facilities private hospitals nursing
homes acute click excuse me acute care
clinics we should have been an
over-under on how many times she uses
the phrase Rear Admiral I didn't know
that would be a thing I've checked and
his team were able to combine data
streams utilize supply chain visuals
visualization tools from DoD and input
data into the cloud this system is now
available to generate reports for
governor's showing what their state
received from the federal government and
commercial partners all the way down to
the hospital level as I noted and thanks
to President Trump and his
administration governor's now have
visibility as to where their supplies
are sent and where they're received and
from March 1st through May 10th this
public-private partnership has led to
the delivery these are extraordinary
numbers of over 113 million in 95
respirator masks nearly half a billion
surgical masks nearly 18 million face
shields and over 12 billion gloves that
is a lot of PPE and we thank our private
sector partners for engaging in this
effort with us also I just wanted to
note that earlier today the president
held an hour-long call with thousands of
Hispanic community business and faith
leaders across the country he recognized
the many contributions of the Hispanic
community to our country and addressed
important issues like how to reopen
their businesses and build the greatest
economy and he bring up those
salads he loves I take questions I just
wanted to note on a separate note that I
wanted to acknowledge the passing of
Ravi Zacharias a renowned Christian
apologist who left this world yesterday
our prayers are with Ravi's family
during this time weird person to mention
at the press briefing station and as my
father said Billy Graham was the great
evangelist and Ravi Zacharias was the
great apologist and we are all thinking
about him and holding him close to our
hearts in his family today and with that
I'll take questions John Bailey what
does the president believe is illegal
about the secretary of state of Michigan
setting up absentee ballot applications
and what federal funding is Lummis
entering withholding from the state of
michigan as a perfect plus oh you know I
won't get into exactly what the funding
considerations are I would note that his
tweets were meant to alert secretary
minuchin and mr. vote about a head of
OMB about his concerns with trillions of
dollars going to these states and his
noted concerns about a lot of fraud that
is potentially at play with the BS yes
with regards to the illegality and
legality of it that's a question for the
campaign as to their voting for a lawyer
maybe she happens to be a lawyer tweet
was meant to alert OMB you wanted to be
very careful as we send trillions of
dollars to states that we keep this
important point in mine and we ensure
that there's fairness in our voting what
some an absolute answer the President
himself has voted just two months ago by
mail
there are several Republican states
they're also doing these mail and
applications for ballots and so I'm
confused what is it that he thinks is
illegal that's happening in Michigan
really specify so first with regards to
the president doing a mail and vote the
president is after all the president
which means he's here in Washington he's
unable to cast his vote down in Florida
his Reza state of residence so for him
that's why he had to do a mail-in vote
but he supports mail-in voting for a
reason when you have a reason that you
are unable to be present yeah avoiding
coronavirus is a valid reason according
to Texas judge I'm glad that you have
the prediction tool and you can tell us
what will be happening on November 3rd
2020 I certainly don't notice the
present Aries coming up and that's like
what's happening in Tuvalu I would also
I assume you care about fairness and
accuracy in our elections do you not
it's not about what she cares about you
can go look this up on Pro Publica there
is a bipartisan consensus on the fact
that mass mail and voting can lead to
fraud there is live commission by none
other than President Carter whose
[ __ ] let me give you guys the
numbers over the last 20 years 250
million people have bailed mailed in
ballots on average there are problems
with 7 to 8 ballots per year not not 7
percent 7 to 8 ballots per year the
president deleted his first tweet which
alleged Fault in of a state official
depending on absolutely balanced
everybody in fact-based send out
absentee ballot requests was the
president misinformed this morning and
why is he only dragging
again not other states on your gloves
anything similar absentee ballot
requests to their sales so the president
corrected his tweet as you noted and
with regard to going state by states and
looking at ballots in the way they're
distributed that would be a question for
the Trump campaign and I'd refer you to
the campaign on that point the g7 you
get any more detail from the time when
the president would like to that
schedule that you learn Washington and
does that mean that travel restrictions
that are currently in place on I've
traveled from from Europe from China in
other places would potentially be
relaxed right before that meeting would
take place here so I won't get into the
mechanics of how that would happen I
would note that the president really
wants to see the g7 happen here in
Washington as we begin not just to
reopen the country but as the world
begins to reopen you'd like to see it
happen sometime in June but as to a
particular date I don't have any
announcement on that front or to the
mechanisms of how we'd make that work a
couple of questions for you one this
president Trump to support the CDC
guidelines that were released over the
weekend and if so why were they released
so quietly CDC guidelines there was a 60
page document that came out last night
that I assume you're referencing on that
document I talked I talked to dr.
Redfield earlier today about it and much
of the movie was already out there so
appendices a B C and D had been out
there for a while appendix e he said he
thinks got posted sometime late last
week and again these were his rough
estimates he was giving me appendix F
was being discussed and there was
constructive criticism of it through the
task force thought interagency process
that was behind in my point in sharing
that with you is that the 60 page
document was merely an aggregation of a
lot of what was already out there so
it's not as if this was new information
that we were announcing but I require
more guidance pursuant to our reopening
of America guidance that was issued
several weeks ago husband's support the
guidelines does he think
and should follow those guidelines or
should they be following the initial
guidelines so the president's been very
clear he supports the reopening of
America guidelines the CDC guidelines
are in concert with those guidelines he
wants to safely reopen this country it's
very important we do so and it's good to
see that most states I think basically
all of them have plans at this point to
reopen and we're starting to see the
safe reopening of several states and
Americans getting back to work we just
get your reaction to something he's
gotten moments ago a statement from the
American Nurses Association which says
quote the American Nurses Association
has not received reports from nurses or
other frontline health care workers
utilizing hydroxychloroquine as a
preventative treatment effective in
tonight
Windsor look like I will continue to say
that many or thousands of frontline
workers are using it as a prophylactic
well there is um at Henry Ford Hospital
is doing a study on this now where 3,000
frontline workers will be taking
hydroxychloroquine to look at X use as a
prophylaxis I believe 100 or a hundred
ninety workers and Tampa General
Hospital's so this is being used by by
some and one thing I want to note with
regard to hydroxychloroquine because I
think it's very important that we're as
accurate as we can be with our reporting
on this hydroxychloroquine has been a
drug that has been in use for 65 years
for lupus arthritis and malaria it was a
very good safety profile but as with any
drug and as with any prescription it
should be given by a doctor to a patient
in that context so no one should be
taking this without a prescription from
their doctor but that being said I've
seen a lot of apoplectic coverage of
hydroxychloroquine Jimmy Kimmel saying
the president's quote trying to kill
himself by taking it you had Joe
Scarborough saying this will kill you
Neil Cavuto saying what have you got to
lose I'm one thing you have to lose our
lives you know Chris Cuomo saying the
president knows that hydroxychloroquine
is not supported by science he knows it
has been flying flat I may not Nobel and
he's using it
well Cuomo mocked the president for this
and interestingly I found this out just
before coming here hydroxychloroquine of
course is an fda-approved medication
with a long proven job record it turns
out that Chris Cuomo took a less safe
version of it called quinine which the
FDA removed from the market in 2006 so
really interesting to have that critics
well know I'd like to redirect him to
his brother the governor of New York
Governor Cuomo who has several
on-the-record statements about
hydroxychloroquine saying I'm an
optimist I'm hopeful about the drug and
that's why I will try it here in New
York as soon as we get it that was like
two months ago
instead it's promising that's why we're
going ahead and I have about eight other
quotes from Governor Cuomo should any of
you have interest in that study though
there are trials that are in their early
phases do you have any evidence that
thousands of frontline workers are
currently using it because they believe
it actually will prevent them from
getting the FDA has approved this for
off-label use you know this president's
a big believes you're not answers right
to try legislation people who that's
bull there are several studies that have
been brought that the president has
actually mentioned that I'd refer you to
there was one out of France a French
study 35 involving more than a thousand
patients that found that the vast
majority had quote good clinical
outcomes and by the vast majority that
was more than 90 percent right so so
most people have good clinical outcomes
because the this is only killing 1% of
people that one didn't demonstrate it
was because of the hydroxy this is a
Gish gallup [ __ ] show my friends this is
unbelievable this is a safe drug to use
in your doctor importantly to underscore
that and your doctor prescribes it for
your use as a prophylaxis or after
coming into contact with kovin then it's
something you should take if it's
prescribed by the doctor and that's your
personal medical choice yes governor de
santis just suggested that the president
made
Florida for the SpaceX NASA launch next
week is that accurate
so we have no news on scheduling at that
front but if I if I get news in the
future I will certainly provide that for
you yes Geoff Keighley how often does
the president talk to director Bullock
or Acting Director vote from the author
to go to the acting director of OMB the
guy who did I he just was in the Oval
Office with the president so they do
speak often I don't have a readout of
the president's schedule but they do
speak regularly he wanted to flag to him
his concerns about Michigan why don't
you just tell him instead of sending a
tweet because the president believes an
unprecedented transparency and I'm sure
you as a journalist Tom are very eager
and excited when you learn about the
president's decision-making process from
wildly accusing people of crimes on
Twitter that's not transparency that's
idiocy reasoning for saying this is a
transparent president and I think that
that's something that you should be
allotting rather than question as to why
he decided to tweet this president macro
do you have any other answers from g7
leaders that they they are willing
definitely willing to come here
so we'll get into the president's
private conversations and
correspondences I'm with world leaders
but we do hope to see this happen we
hope that how can you characterize the
response as being great how's that good
idea or thinking about it so I don't
have any information about the response
from world leaders but we certainly hope
to see this happen right yes yes thank
you could you clarify please president
Trump's comments about saying that it
was a good idea it was good that there
were so many positive tests for for cope
at 19 whereas a lot of people look at
that and say that this was actually a
terrible that we have absolutely one
third of all the cases in the world well
look I would note this that what he was
saying there is that we are testing when
you have more cases in order to identify
those cases you have to have tested a
high volume of people so the more you
test the more cases numerically not
necessarily as a percent positive but
numerically you will see just by volume
sheer volume of your testing and the
president's done an extraordinary job on
this front what number were 38th and
testing per capita is in state health
department's and found that at least a
dozen states
have testing capacity that outstrips the
supply of patience that's okay that's
because they're not starting to do the
surveilling surveillance testing we need
to do so that's it that's a [ __ ]
talking point to sites and more testing
capacity than we're using so we're
testing a lot and thus we're finding a
number of cases but as we safely reopen
we do have some encouraging I don't even
know that she believes this stuff see a
week over week decline a 15% decline in
deaths in just the last week April 1st
to mid-may 50% decline a new
hospitalization in under 25,000 cases
today so we are seeing progress the
Secretary of State in Michigan wrote by
sending out the applications and did the
Secretary of State in Georgia also break
that law by sending out applications for
it there was no idea I referenced you to
the campaign these are ballot questions
and references why would you ask a
campaign about state voting laws when
you'd really need lawyers ballot so I
would refer you to the campaign on that
front and I would note to you that many
of those ballots that are submitted via
mail can be fraudulent I cited to the
bipartisan study I can occasionally not
an issue 7 to 8 fraudulent mail-in
ballots per year a Democrat not a
Republican and James Baker concluded
that these ballots from the largest
source of potential voter fraud so if
you cast a ballot on via mail and you
know fraudulently that would be an
illegal act and I'd point you to that
and for further I'd point you to my
former employer which is the Trump
campaign there's seven to eight of those
per year yes Thank You Kelly two
questions if I may
firstly on airports the TSA is
reportedly considering setting up
temperature checks at airports given the
numbers of people who can be
asymptomatic or sick without a fever do
you think that's sufficient and why was
it worked on you to have screening at
airports sooner particularly in light of
the house oversight investigators Trump
said for months that they were already
doing that and now this guy's like yeah
the TSA is thinking about it and um is
working with TSA he's working with
Airlines we want to ensure that our TSA
employees are safe that those who are
traveling are safe and he has had those
conversations and we are keeping people
safe at the TSA and the passengers as
well
over 500 TSA employees they become sick
and six are dead so again you know do
you think this has been enough action
and soon enough we've taken action we're
working with the TSA we're keeping on
America's essential workers safe and we
are praying for all of those who have
been affected by crime on another first
I wanted to ask about the president's
son and business partner Eric Trump he
recently said a firown' virus that quote
the Democrats are trying to milk this
and predicted it will quote magically
all of a sudden go away and disappear
and everyone will be able to reopen
after the election in November if you
think earth Trump's comments are
accurate and also appropriate I think we
all hope coronavirus goes away and I
think we as we continue to take the
president his family out of context we
should endeavor it's not out of cousin
accuracy and I think we should all hope
that the coronavirus goes after we
should all look at the coronavirus goes
away yes is there a timeline for when
you can European
and visitors are allowed to come back
into the United States and will all
European countries be included or could
it be a case-by-case basis so we don't
have a timeline on that just yet I can
tell you the president's preeminent
concern is keeping Americans safe his
travel restrictions have saved lives as
dr. Falchi and others have noted so we
don't have an announcement will be
ruinous back priority his number one
concern is America first and held them
well-being of the nation first yeah
thankfully a spokesman for governor
Whitmer said that she's been planning to
meet with resin
application tomorrow is what are you
there's a reason why that would be
governor Whitner with mercy or in in
Michigan wasn't extended in invitation
to the president's appearance in
Michigan tomorrow tomorrow and I was
wondering if there's a reason why I
don't think there was a particular
reason I it didn't come up but you know
while I on that note I would point to
governor Whitmer I have an invitation
but she should be quite happy that
thanks to this federal government FEMA
obligated more than two hundred sixteen
point two million dollars to Michigan
eight point six million n95 respirator
seven hundred forty thousand eighteen
surgical masks three hundred 1571 face
shields I should round these up or we'll
be here all day seven hundred sixty
thousand gloves seven hundred
ventilators the president has done quite
a bit for Michigan and her concerns an
invitation but she should be thanking
the president for all the supplies that
he's delivered to her sight yes yes
clearly the president has made clear
that he's concerned about liability
issues as companies reopen now it's the
White House engaged with Republican
senators about this issue and would the
president sign another fill another
Kovach bill without liability being
addressed in that so I won't lay out the
president's conditions or lack thereof
for any upcoming legislation he has
mentioned it that it's something that
needs to be looked at closely and he is
looking at closely and he is discussing
with members of the hill about that but
he has made clear in terms of the phase
four that he wants to be slow as we
approach a phase four and not rush
forward with spending trillions more
dollars of taxpayer money we've we've
done a lot so far and I look at doing
more in the future and liabilities
definitely something that he's concerned
about him working on right back there oh
one more on g7
do you think that would be appropriate
to hold a g7 summit in the US while
ordinary citizens are still not allowed
to travel freely for example from Europe
yeah the president wants us to start
reopening travel restrictions are
something that you know he wants to make
sure American lives are protected before
those are lifted but that being said I
do think it's entirely appropriate so
does the president have a g7 here
America's reopening the world's
reopening right there's no job but a
show of strength and optimism to have
all of the leaders of these countries
come together at the White House and
pursue business as usual and as we move
forward through this pandemic right to
pretend it's business as usual okay so
we'll do it we'll do it president Trump
is counsel to the president G and also
has said that called his response to the
coronavirus deadly classified as a
deadly mishandled what's the White
House's response to it um so you said
that that came from Susan Rice was it
okay so first I would want to take a
moment to address the president's
response because the president has had
an extraordinary an early response to
the coronavirus Sunhwa I would know dr.
Burks the early work of President Trump
both the travel restrictions and
quarantine has bought us the time and
space necessary to have this task force
be very effective dr. Faustus because
response has been impressive he can't
imagine under any circumstance that
anyone could be doing anything more I
can go through the actions there's a
detailed timeline out there of January
6th on wuhan issuing a travel and travel
notice issued on wuhan when there were
zero cases in the United States the 17th
zero reported US cases and there were
Public Health entry screenings at major
US airports of course the infamous
travel restrictions that were called
xenophobic by Democrats on January 31st
a lot of action in February on
developing a test on in making sure
weird like if Trump's response has been
the best in the world why are we one of
the worst off countries in the world he
was saying come to Chinatown it's
very safe but the president had already
taken very early action and I know you
brought up Susan Rice in that context
but I'm going to bring her up in another
context that's equally as a new
newsworthy and that is the email that
was Declassified you're not gonna get an
answer from Susan Rice on Inauguration
Day which is so peculiar if set the
scene it's an odd Eurasian day you're
moving out of the White House this is
the most powerful building on planet
earth Susan Rice is moving out to
reflecting on her time here and what is
she doing she's not packing your boxes
why not he wrote in being nostalgic
about her time in the White House what
she's doing is writing an email worth
three times she writes that President
Obama emphasized who conduct the
investigation into Michael Flynn by the
book by the book by the book she writes
that three times as a Shakespeare said
thou doth protest too much Susan Rice he
didn't have the Susan Rice part in there
but I'll add that in to she was asked
about the unmasking and Michael Flynn a
fruit after she discussed it on January
5th in the Oval Office with Obama after
she wrote this the Obama there's not
anything in here that's an answer to the
question Judy Woodruff
about this email and shooting about the
unmasking of Michael Flynn not the email
but the a masking she was asked
specifically about Nunez exclaims
specifically really no well what is that
I know nothing about this so it was a
lie
and then Susan Rice and stolen brought
it up to me I will bring it up to you
her attorney said that this was the
first opportunity three weeks after this
oval office meeting that she had to
write this email memorializing her oval
office meeting with a Barack Obama
discussing Michael Flynn it was her
first opportunity she said interesting
because she had an opportunity in those
three weeks on January 10th this is the
Bataan event with none other than
Michael Flanders almost grease wish Tim
success and talked about the great
transition into the White House and then
on January 12th she was able to
participate in a story that published on
that date in the lifestyle section of
The Washington Post says she never had
time to write this email until
inauguration day as she's rushing out
the door when in fact she had all of
those things I'll leave that with you
thank you for bringing up Susan Rice not
in the Khan
that I wished but for allowing me to
share that oh my god she didn't even
answer the question and she's just
leaving like that there was nothing
there that was even remotely an answer
to the question that was extraordinarily
embarrassing like that that was that was
crazy
she almost like ran out without even
answering that question unbelievable and
how do we know how long that was how
long did that go it's gotta be about 20
minutes again yeah I don't know exactly
when it started hold on let's see if we
go back ok 26 minutes alright so we
would have been the over would've won
with my 23 minute but that was certainly
certainly pretty close all right thank
you everybody for joining me very much
appreciate seeing you all here we did
get to 25 members the next stream will
be the man-bun stream but until then I
will see you soon
you